hi everyone my name is Yasin I work in
research Karma and
who's excited about some machine
learning
yes
I heard that I haven't started
presenting yet and I already have some
questions so I guess I'll answer them
later don't forget
so today I'm going to talk to you about
our progress in learning a driving
simulator
so it's been a few months of of this
project and we have some exciting
results and I would like to talk to you
about them
um
before I start I would like to show you
approximately where we're heading after
this presentation so as you might have
guessed none of these videos are real
all of them are imagined all of them are
are predicted using the machine learning
model
of which we give a few frames of context
and then ask the model to predict the
next few frames in here about a minute
of frames
and uh
yeah as you can see the videos look
pretty good it's important consistency
is pretty good too
so this is a minute of rollout as I said
they exhibit some really nice properties
you can see that some Physics is learned
some some great Dynamics has learned as
well for the night videos you can also
see that the lighting looks pretty good
which is something we really care about
um and I'll come back to this slide
after we're done but pretty much by the
end of this presentation you should
pretty much understand how we built this
and why is it useful to us and what are
our next steps
but before let's go back to the basics
why do we even need a simulator
Harold talked about this this morning
we've talked about this two years ago in
the previous Comic Con why even a
simulator
without a simulator the driving model
will never be exposed to any kind of
significant noise or any kind of
significant deviations especially the
noise introduced from its own mistakes
so
if we train a model outside of a
simulator without a simulator what's
going to happen is if you end up outside
of the center of the lane the model will
always say just keep doing whatever
you're doing and recover later we'll
cover in a few seconds and the next
second it will also do the same thing
also say yeah you're pretty good just
just keep going and then recover the
center
in a few seconds and the result of this
is what you see in the bottom video it's
basically a model that doesn't recover
to the center of the lane and just
drifts outside of the lane
so this is a problem and we need a
simulator for this
now a good question to ask ourselves as
well is why not a classical simulator
why do all these complicated things why
not just build a Unity or an audio
engine simulator GTA 5 kind of simulator
and why not just do that well
I'm not saying that this is a bad thing
these simulators are good for testing we
want them we want them for testing
because they're good for you know the
deterministic they're fully
you can build whatever you want you can
build whatever scenario but we want to
use this for training and training it is
a whole different Beast first of all you
need to match the training distribution
you need to match the real world
distribution of driving data and what is
even that how do you even quantify that
and how do you even know that you did
that you matched the real world
and even if you try to do this you would
actually need to hard code a bunch of
scenarios a lot of them and every day
you'll just be building a simulator you
never do self-driving just be building a
simulator and that's not really a
business that we want to be in so as you
understand as you might understand this
is not a scalable solution you don't
want to be hard-coding simulators for
training at least
so we came up with this thing called the
small offset simulator and Harold talked
about this this morning as well it's
basically a simulator in which we shift
the image a little to the right a little
to the left a little to the forward a
little backward to simulate little
movements uh from the original position
and when we train the model in this
simulator in closed loop we actually see
driving we see a model that recovers we
see a model that stops for stop signs
which is a model that stops for red
lights and this is quite amazing so this
is a small offset simulator and that's
what we've been running with for a few
years now
but as you might have guessed we're
trying to go past it so why are we even
trying to go past here what's wrong with
it
well Harold hinted at the problem this
morning which we call cheating
so in order to have a very good
simulator of the sort of this small
offset simulation you want to have
really good ground root you want to have
good highest estimation good road plane
estimation good pose estimation and so
many good things they need to be pretty
much perfect and the problem is as soon
as you start to get some imperfections
some error you will have
similar artifacts and those artifacts
um can tell the model which which way
you came from or how to how to drive
basically so the model will learn how to
drive just by looking at the artifacts
instead of learning how to drive like a
normal human being
and trust me the model knows how to
cheat
so this is the first problem
the second problem is well it's in the
title it's a small offset simulator it's
not a big offset simulator so as as long
as as soon as we try to do some kind of
big offsets you can see that the images
look very funky and they really don't
look that good you don't want to drive
in this world
and that really doesn't matter for
lateral that much because you don't
deviate so much left to right while
driving laterally but Elon should know
this makes a big difference at highway
speeds plus minus 10 miles an hour it's
really a big distance so you really want
big offset Simulator for launch should
know
so
this is it this is our state right now
and why do we want to go past it so how
do we do this well
I'll tell some history here in 2016
Heather and George wrote a paper called
learning a driving simulator and I stole
the title of my presentation from this
paper
you don't have to read the paper you can
read it if you want but I'm going to
basically explain what the paper is
about today
the paper basically described what we're
doing now is just read 2016 Tech you
don't want to be doing 2016 machine
learning we want today's machine
learning 2016 machine learning sucks
this is what what 2016 machine learning
give you and
as you saw the first slide 2023 machine
learning is a lot better than this
so
what's an ml simulator so we're trying
to build an ml simulator
and ml simulator is basically three
parts three components
and I'm going to go into each component
separately and explain what it does and
yeah by the end we'll go back to our
first slide so three components image
tokenizer a post tokenizer and the
dynamic Transformer I will explain every
part separately
so an image tokenizer is basically a
fancy image compressor it's an ml image
compressor that takes in images and
compresses them into a set of tokens now
what's a token a token is just a fancy
name for a discrete number a number that
can only attend a small set of values
from a dictionary so
taking images images is a lot of pixels
then encodes them into this set of
tokens that are discrete usually these
tokens are not too much 128 512 tokens
and then with this tokenizer usually
comes a d tokenizer or an image decoder
that can bring you back to image space
and in which you can see what you
actually compressed and then compare it
this model is trained with the Gan loss
with a generative adversarial loss and
this is what is usually referred to as a
VQ gun
so yes this is a our image tokenizer
and in this slide
I show from left to right a source image
an image compressed to 520 bits and an
image compressed to 1280 bits
so I want to point out a few details
here that are that are pretty
interesting do you notice this es logo
here
notice how it's a little funky around
here but it's still some right things
around that area but notice that the
1280 bits just completely forgot about
the CVS logo we don't really need that
what what do you need logos in life
um you can also notice that the building
uh a little at the distance here looks
okay for the 512 45 1200 for 5920 bits
image but the 1280 image looks pretty
funky uh the traffic light also looks a
little funky
um so yeah these are completely
classical compression artifacts that we
get here
um so the image this image is there's a
lot happening there's a traffic light
there's a logo there's buildings so it's
a complex image
for a pretty classic highway driving
image you really can see the difference
this looks really similar to me and so
for highway driving either 512 or 1200
that really doesn't make that much
difference and in order to iterate fast
so we want to iterate fast and we know
we can improve the quality of our
simulation by just scaling up the number
of bits in order to iterate fast do some
good experimentation we're working now
with this with this model but we know
that in the future as as our models
improve we can always scale up and get
better simulation so for now
128 tokens 10 bits each
now what's a post tokenizer what's
supposed to start with the oppose is
basically six floating points numbers uh
they're six degrees of freedom basically
your X speed y speed Z speed and then uh
your roll rates pitch rates and uh your
rate so we also need to uh to tokenize
these numbers uh just because of the
next component that I'm going to talk
about but trust me we need to do that
and we tokenize them with a very simple
tokenizer we basically need to digitize
them or to quantize them so we just
digitize them with the uniform binning
very simple nothing fancy here
um
now to the beefy part
the Dynamics Transformer who knows what
a Transformer is
yes who's used shot GPT
same people some people more people yeah
I see you cool
so yeah Transformer is is basically the
same architecture as a large language
model gpg llama these kind of these kind
of models
for large language models a token is
roughly speaking one word a sentence is
a set of tokens and the document or
paragraph is a set of sets of tokens for
us an image is a set of tokens a video
is a set of images so a set of set of
tokens and we train it with the same way
the large logos models people do very
nice loss function cross entropy predict
the next token
so very similar to large to large
language models this is
this is the architecture of a
transformer for those who don't know
what a Transformer is it's basically a
fancy machine learning architecture
that's a stack of
fully connected layers and attention
layers so just a black box of a machine
learning architecture
so we use this Dynamics Transformer uh
one token at a time so it's Auto
aggressive sampling at each time we ask
the model what is what do you think the
next token will be we take that token
plug that back in in the inputs then ask
ask it again what would be the next
token
plugs out back in in the inputs and do
this until we reach a number of frames
these number of frames will give us a
sorry this number of tokens will give us
a frame we take that and then do this as
many times as we want until we reach
whatever number of frames we want so
this is what people usually refer to as
Auto aggressive sampling
Auto aggressive sampling so predicting
each token at a time so in theory doing
this is really powerful because you
could cover the whole distribution of
your training set
so you could cover the whole
distribution of possible rollouts given
given a context given a few frames this
could imagine any type of Futures which
is really desirable because you don't
want to restrict whatever happened next
whatever the driving model that will be
trained in the simulator you don't want
to restrict it to something specific you
want it to be as general as possible and
this is really desirable we tried a few
things
to speed up this Auto aggressive
sampling so it's a little slow we're
trying to speed it up we're trying
something that division like sampling uh
some fancy techniques Mass get and
things like that but we didn't really
succeed at anything like that we'll keep
trying and something will will work and
we basically want to speed up the other
aggressive sampling which is a little
slow
so we do all this and it works
this is our
Dynamics model this is our simulator
so in here we just show it we just tell
it to drive straight
and as you can see drive straight
um
it's a pretty nice Highway drive
straight driving
but we can also ask it to do some things
like yank the steering wheel to the
right turn right as much as you want and
as you can see turns right changes Lanes
even goes out of the road even drives on
the grass that's pretty impressive
I guess some people did that in the
training set
who did that
you can also tell it to turn left cross
the median drive in drive to the
opposite lane even get close to oncoming
traffic who did that let's okay I don't
want to know
you can also tell it to accelerate so
notice the Ley lines it passes the
traffic because it passes some traffic
so as you can see there's some
acceleration happening in this in this
rollout
you can also to break so again notice
the lay lines they will slow down so
as you can see successfully breaks
and as a side note we open sourced all
this open source a data set of a hundred
thousand minutes of driving tokenized so
these are all tokenized with the
tokenizer that I've showed before we
open source the image tokenizer and the
image decoder and we also open sourced a
Transformer that's very similar to the
one I'm showing you today and that can
generate rollouts that look like the one
that I showed you today
we also have two one thousand dollar
bounties so if anyone feels
um feels like a weekend project
we want to decrease inference latency we
want to make this model run fast today
they run at 2fps so we want to run them
really fast
so if you improve the training latency
the inverse latency by 50 you get a
thousand dollars and if you decrease
training loss by five percent you also
get a thousand dollars so if anyone
wants a weekend project really fun
another side note
and so I've been showing you all these
images that went back to image space so
these videos that look good it's always
good that we can go back to image space
and debug these Dynamics these Dynamics
models and see what happens but in order
to train a driving model we actually
don't need to go back to True Vision
space we don't need to go back to the
image space you can drive you can train
the model directly on the tokens
which is interesting so these images are
compressed to these tokens and these
tokens have everything you need to know
to drive which is pretty cool so instead
of having like a convolutional neural
network that takes in an image and
predicts the plan and predicts the Ley
lines and such now we have a Transformer
and then you have a plan and the
landline and all that and as you can see
here
it works it predicts the landlines
predicts the plan uh predicts some
reasonable art but so you don't need we
don't technically need to go back to
Vision space in order to train them all
we can directly train it on tokens which
is pretty nice
another side note is that you've noticed
that the images are a little flickery so
they jump a little bit the clouds jump a
little bit the clouds jump a little bit
so and we were aware of that we know
that our encoder is not smooth and
that's because our encoder is frame by
frame there's no temporal consistency
because there's no nothing that's
trained temporally so we want to fix
that then there's multiple ways you can
fix this we really want to have a
tokenizer that's video based that's not
image based what we're doing now is a
little naive you don't want to do this
frame by frame you really want to do it
for a set of frames to get some more
some more quantization you can get more
compression if you compress multiple
frames but there is a technique that
people have been trying and we tried
that as well is to have
a to just freeze everything and then put
a record layer in your decoder which
essentially gives the the decoder like a
state that get passed from frame to
frame and the decoder can use that to
smooth the rollout so as you can see
here in the left is the raw rollout and
uh to the right is the smooth rollout so
much more much much smoother
so this works
um another side note is okay how do we
use this to train how why and what's
what what was missing for us to use this
to train
um we need a new loss function and why
do we need a new loss function well for
sufficiently long rollouts the simulator
is going to imagine things that were
never in the context right this it's
going to imagine traffic lights it's
going to imagine turns it's going to
imagine curves on the highway and these
are going to be very far from the
context because we don't condition on
anything we just tell the model to
imagine something
so the human path that we have been
using so far to train will be Irrelevant
for sufficiently longer rollouts
so we need to come up with something new
uh we don't exactly know what to do and
how and how to do it but the idea is
going to be something close to like a
value model that like either a gun loss
or something like uh like something to
minimize this engagements or something
to basically another model that's
trained separately that quantifies
whether you're roll out to whether
you're driving is good or not based
based on about based on the rollout that
you're showing it so something like a
value model as a loss function instead
of just Mae that we've been using for a
long time
so what are the next steps
a few uh weeks ago we tweeted sorry we
axed uh we X the video of our simulator
and the response some of the some of the
comments were funny but most most of all
they they really show what we need to
work on and what we actually work on so
I'm going to show some of the comments
the comments on the comments
a Harrison uh really wants to play this
he says please let me play it we want to
play it too it's really fun but as I
said it's at 2fps we don't want to play
a game at 2fps so we really want to make
this faster
and that's something we're currently
working on we have bounties on it and
yeah we just want to make this faster
John said there is a left turn on red
and
this person said oh this is a green
light
and we know we know this we can see we
have eyes too uh this this potato
quality image and as I said this is 128
tokens 10 bits each so we know there's
compression artifacts but in order to
move fast in order to experiment faster
we're using this now we'll scale up when
we have either better video tokenizers
uh better sampling strategies so we will
scale up uh we just need to work on
these problems first
Leo said I feel like building the
simulator is not that hard
trust me Leo
Leo we do things not because they're
easy but because we thought they were
easy
so this is basically I've been talking
about uh the auto aggressive sampling
using yeah using actually using the
models scaling the bits and scaling the
Transformer as well and we need better
videos organizers
so going back to this slide these uh
these beautiful rollouts I'd like to
point out some nice properties uh look
at this lead car here where the the the
headlights turn on when it stops and
then they turn off when it goes on so
it's pretty nice
uh some of these rollouts are actually
really good how do you know if this is a
fake video or not this looks really good
this one as well looks quite nice
in this one the model takes an exit
and uh this one the model takes a does a
lane change then takes an exit which is
quite interesting the Night videos also
look good look at these lights light
Hollows that look really uh really
realistic
again fancy buildings
weird weird looking buildings as I've
shown in the tokenizer slide and this is
really because the tokenizer is terrible
but yeah you can see the building move
like it's a really good physics
understanding uh The Prompt of this
image has a cable so some people don't
hide the cables from in front of the
cameras which is not a big problem but
you can see that the cable stays there
pretty consistent in the frames
this one here it's a Snowy Road and the
snow persists after the rollout so the
snow is still there at the end of dorola
which is really interesting
and this one the model just want to stop
and takes a picture I guess of of uh of
the surrounding I don't know maybe a
Mountain Road or something
so
yeah this is this is it this is Drive
GPT
any questions
so you mentioned that you can get like
an initial image and then you can also
say that move straight or like move
right so are you conditioning on
language at all like the tokens
um okay so we don't condition our
language uh I was talking about the pose
which is the six numbers six numbers are
essentially moving so the your speed
lateral speed longitudinal speed and z
in the Z axis so those are the the
numbers that we use to condition the
model to go left or right or to go
faster or slower so we have those number
baked in the model so those are special
tokens call them the post tokens and
those are used to condition so we can
either let the model Go free falling so
the model also also predicts those
tokens so the model knows which are the
most likely next pose so we can either
run the model with those and we the
model will be unconditioned so we just
use those from the model or we can just
go in and say sell to the model no no no
this is not what we want we want to go
right and then put those tokens in and
the output of this thing will be a
conditioned video
does that answer the question we have a
question here
well
great question
awesome talk thank you um I have a
question about the bottlenecks in your
pipeline what's the like top bottlenecks
in pipeline to inference it for real
time
so these models are quite big even
though they're not as big as GPT and
llama they're they're a little big and
we're currently bottlenecked by software
we're not reaching
if I am bandwidth or not even reaching
flops bandwidth so we're just really
bottlenecked by good software
inferencing GPT models Transformer
models uh currently we just use Onyx
which is a pretty standard inference
engine and there are some fancy ones
that are coming up and uh yeah so
currently we're bottlenecked by by
software
when we reach the limits of the software
we'll probably need either to uh to do
some tricks on the architecture to make
it faster or
just use more gpus
all right
thanks for the talk
um So eventually maybe these uh rollouts
will be at least human indistinguishable
from real rollouts yeah
um what applications open up when you
get there
so the first application we see here is
really learning the learning Indus
driving simulator so we want to use this
we replace completely replace our small
offset simulator and the driving model
is basically going to live in this world
it's going to drive around go grocery
shopping go to the movie theater and
just learn how to drive in this in this
in this driving simulator I mean other
applications might pop up I don't know
like a game or something but uh but for
now we're focused on learning a driving
model in the simulator
um
are you worried about uh using too much
of this learned uh simulation in your
models and causing a model collapse
a model collapse
um so I guess you're uh
referencing
training on iteratively training on
models and that would cause a model
collapse well that happens
when the models are
we have proved that this happened for
models that are similar so let's say you
train chat gbt on charge gbt data on
charge DB data and you do this
iteratively the model will collapse it
also has been showed to exist for image
generation data as well but the models
that we will train here are very
different this model as a simulator is
going to
is going to basically learn how to
imagine driving data but the model that
we'll train on it is a completely
different model it's a model that learns
how to drive so these will be very
different and we're not going to do this
iteratively there's going to be just a
one step process and we will improve
both of the models independently but
there's not going to be any any
iterative process so we are aware of the
model collapse but we don't see it as an
issue for now and yeah is that answer
your question yeah
I have a two question one do you
consider using mask or to encoder that
can Compass about that in the person
of the unity and the second way is you
talk about a video encoder if you use a
video incredible then
forward to the
Transformer model
it should be output also a video as well
is that correct
yeah so your first question was about
mass auto encoders and that's what I was
referring to as maskit or similar
approaches to train image tokenizers and
such we tried it didn't really work that
well
but yeah it didn't really work that well
what worked well is the cleanest
solution the most obvious one worked
well we tried to go fancier and it
didn't work so I guess there's something
to learn here then your next question
was uh PVP next question I forgot
if you have a video included that means
if you put this
audio includer the code
to the Transformer okay if you go to the
forward it should be General every token
is a video is that correct uh so what
would have uh was referring to as a vid
as a video decoder is something close to
like an INB frame uh kind of tokenizer
so some different types of tokenizer
what would be like a like a general
iframe and then a p frame that's a
smaller set of tokens or smaller
basically more compression in the diff
frames so this is what I was referring
to as a video Talk video encoder but
again this is something we haven't done
yet and uh I guess we'll we'll see we'll
see what will work and we'll see what
other people are trying and try to try
to navigate in this in this research
area
um is the
so it uh is it is the output from the
simulator only is used to train the
policy model because the way I
understand there's two models there's
the vision which is like efficient net
B2 and then the uh policy model okay so
you're you're one of the questions from
before right
no no okay sure so I I guess I will
answer both questions
um uh there's one question before about
why we say there's two models while we
also say that we're end to end uh so
there are two models and uh when we say
we train end to end uh it's because
these two models really have the same
loss function these two models are
pretty the same thing these two models
predict what is the plan and then
they just predict the plan this is the
only thing we use we use the plan from
the model the visual model predicts the
plan and the policy model as well
predicts the plan now why do we need two
models we need two models exactly
because we need a simulator so these two
models are living in two different
worlds division model lives in the real
world and the policy model lives in the
simulated world so we did the split
because this model needs to be trained
in different worlds and
and yeah so we're still end to end
because we're not using any bounding
boxes we're not using any perception
kind of layer that says or these are
these are traffic lights and such so um
so yeah I hope this answer the first
question and uh the second question uh
yes this uh simulator will so the policy
model will be trained on this on the
simulator but not not the vision model
all right
hey great presentation
um my question as you as a researcher
I'm sure you know there's been so many
advancements in AI so my question is
regarding
how do you balance researching testing
and you know playing around with all the
recent developments in for example
tokenizers that's the topic that I want
to focus on you know all the new
tokenizers that come out how do you
focus on testing out and you know
working playing around with all those
new developments from other teams but
also clearly developing your own stuff
since you're a researcher you you wanna
build your own stuff so how do you
balance
so keeping up with with state of the art
is it's pretty hard there's a lot of
things that are happening right now
machine learning is growing very fast
but there's one signal that I've noticed
is that I mean you don't really want to
be the first one to replicate a paper
this is it's kind of a useless thing to
do unless you really it's actually doing
it to learn or unless you're doing it to
practice or you're interested in this
personally but replica being the first
person to replicate
um
it's not that that good so you want to
wait for other people to replicate and
see see fill the waters and see if
something looks useful or not and
usually this takes about a week or two
people are very active
and then pushing the state of the art
again uh you really want to balance
being at the edge of state of the art or
pushing it a little far and uh I come
over trying to push it what we need to
push it and there's a lot of researcher
outside of comma there's a lot of people
a lot of labs that are working on the
same problems and it'll be good if they
did the work for us but sometimes they
don't so we try to leverage their work
as much as we can and we also open
source our stuff so it's not like a
one-way Highway here we open source our
findings right blog posts we will
publish data sets so when we see the
need to push the state of the art we do
it and then we share with people it's
not it's um yeah it's just a little line
that we need to balance but uh but so
far worked great
uh my question is where do the model
names come from what do Nicki Minaj and
Nicholas Cage have to do with driving
great question I don't know if I'm
allowed to say am I allowed to say
Trade Secrets we don't have a lot of
Secrets but trait secret okay we're
gonna keep these
I had some questions about just that
tokenizer aspect in general like what
motivates to stick to like these
discrete tokens
what's the motivation between sticking
to like this discrete token
representation versus
um like maybe a more regressive like
doing regression is that just because
like cross-entropy loss is so simple and
nice or is there something else and then
a couple more questions about the tokens
is there like some position dependency
on those have you tried looking at like
the interpret like have you tried
interpreting what token 95 means for
example
oh yeah great questions so we tokenized
because cross entropy is the best loss
function everyone knows that
whatever else is uh just a scam it
doesn't work
uh but yeah cross entropy is the best
last function it's really simple uh it's
uh yeah I I can talk a lot about why
cross entropy is good but it's not
really the The Talk today
um
your next question the question was
about interpreting the tokens so these
are like visual tokens so you can you
can like feed an image of just token one
one one one one one one and then see
what the decoder says and these will be
like basically colors or basic uh basic
uh the patterns or you know zigzags and
stuff like that edges and things like
that so these are visual patterns and
they have they do have positional
information
um and uh the Transformer has a position
encoding as most Transformers but I
heard that we don't really need these
positional encodings but we still have
it but yeah they have we can interpret
them we can see what each stroker looks
like we can see if our tokenizer is
efficient or not we can see if like all
token all the tokens have been utilized
and also can mean different things so
you can somewhat interpret these tokens
and they have positional information as
well
say driving is very different around the
world I was wondering if you looked into
conditioning on geolocation
uh that's a good uh that's a good
question up there's multiple ways we can
condition these things we can condition
them on weather we can condition them on
on geolocation we can condition them on
type of car and Citizen and so on uh we
don't really want to go in this detail
we just want to build the most General
simulator possible if someone wants to
condition them on on uh on Country if
the data set is open source uh they can
they can condition them on on countries
and and look at data from Venezuela or
from Uganda or anything so yeah we just
want to build the most General simulator
we want to condition it on the least
possible things
thanks for the talk um I was curious I
know Harold mentioned the long-term goal
of comma being
um from going from just cars to broader
areas like robotics so I was wondering
first of all if you plan to use the same
like GPT style simulator and just how
you think it scales to something like
robotics where you have more degrees of
freedom and maybe a different like
distribution of output spaces
yeah great question this is one of the
main motivators of using this simulator
is that it can scale to any type of
Robotics problem
um it has more more degrees of freedom
but we use the very simple post
tokenizers which is MP digitized if you
have more degrees of freedom you just
use a more fancy tokenizer for that this
really scales to any type of of dynamic
of of Robotics problem you want to want
to do and as you can see most recent
robotics uh fancy looking Solutions now
use something that looks like this so
we're really excited about how we can
extend this to something outside of
driving as well
hey thank you so
we're not related so I'm thinking about
this scenario say this is for uh is it
for the input for the driving model
right so right now I was saying okay I
want to drive from a and to B for
example please give me please give me
the scenario of driving to the nearest
Taco Bell but this is a language right
I'm just curious why we don't put
language as the you know the first input
and generate the you know actually the
driving video scenarios
yeah we don't really need language
I mean we can condition anything which
floats with floating points numbers
language is very inefficient why not use
something that has a lot more bits than
uh Than Words
um we can condition it on text some
people are doing it
um we we really can do it we can just
connect this to an llm connect this to
Lamas 7B and then put the put the text
and get the embedding and then plug it
back into the GPT that's something we
can do we haven't been doing this I mean
these are really cool demos right the
the code for papers they're fun things
to do we've really been trying to to
make something as general as possible
and yeah again if someone wants to do
this really easy
um just uh you know plug it back with
the Llama 2 and see what happens it's a
could be a cool project
we got one last question here in the
back
cool um could you speak a little bit
more about the temporal consistency
aspects in particular I mean the the
training data is temporarily consistent
so kind of what's the intuition behind
why the predictive model is unable it
like has some flickering and why it's
not able to learn temporal consistency
and then what are the core ideas between
like I know you had a slide on it but I
didn't quite understand the core ideas
that enable the loss of flickering Okay
so
let me go back to it
it's it's going to be white light mode
so why does the model not predict Smooth
video on its own uh well because the
data is not smooth the data it's trained
on is tokenized frame by frame so the
data that the model is is trained on
isn't good it's flickers so even the
ground truth data of this model flickers
um and this flickers because the
tokenizer is frame by frame it doesn't
have any temporal memory it doesn't have
any smoothness to it it's just frame by
it just it just it flickers and I mean a
good question would be why does it
flicker why is it not pretty smooth and
it flickers because there's compression
right we're asking this model to really
compress this really hard
um so it will Flicker and we notice that
the more bits we use the less flicker
when we see so this is to answer your
first question uh what is it flicker
then uh the smoothing decoder basically
is just sticking an RNN layer just
sticking a layer that has a memory and
at each step we share that memory to the
next step and then doing this we we have
like a running State and doing so the
decoder has more information now and
knows how to smooth the decoder didn't
have that information before I didn't
know what happened a second ago didn't
know what happened the frame ago so it
couldn't even smooth now it can smooth
and as you can see it works
does that answer your question
okay
all right give it up for your scene
thank you